So I'm really excited to introduce Joanne Chang.
She is the co owner and pastry chef at flower bakery and cafe with four
locations in Boston and Cambridge as well as the co owner of Myers and chain.
Um,
this is her third visit to our office and she has three cookbooks now.
So I'm looking forward to her fourth visit to us maybe soon.
Um,
please join me in welcoming Joanne chain of here.
So,
uh,
I am really excited that I get to talk to you about this because I love to bake
and it's something that I've loved to do since I was a really,
I think like eight years old and my parents never really baked much.
So I started doing making cookies and cakes and everything.
Um,
the low sugar thing is interesting and it's been something that I think a lot of
people are interested in learning more about.
What made you start to decide to do a cookbook about that?
Yep.
It certainly wasn't anything that I had planned kind of all along,
like the first baking book flower,
I'd always wanted to write a baking book.
The second book flower too was kind of a natural offshoot of the first one
because there are a lot of people who like to eat savory things.
And at the bakery we do a lot of sandwiches and soups and salads.
And so after the first book came out,
a lot of people,
a lot of our customers said,
you know what happened to all of the savory part of your menu?
And so that led to the second book.
So this third book,
baking with less sugar was not kind of in the,
in my plan until I started to think,
okay,
next book,
what should I do?
I really enjoy writing books.
And honestly,
the next book was supposed to be the Meyers and Chang Book.
Um,
that will be your fourth.
That is going to be the fourth visit.
And we did just sign a deal for the fourth book so that one will be forthcoming.
But,
uh,
what happened was I was starting to write the proposal for the Meyers and Chang
Book and a couple,
like two or three things happen all at once.
Um,
one at home for myself and my husband.
I eat sugar all day long.
I mean that's part of my job is to go to all the bakeries and taste the things
that we make.
Um,
and fortunate for me,
I don't have a problem with sugar.
I've been eating it all my,
you know,
my whole life and I love it.
My husband loves sugar,
but he is somebody who,
he definitely goes through kind of sugar highs and sugar lows and I will use to
bring stuff home from the bakery.
And after eating it,
um,
he would just crash.
And I started to try to figure out ways that I could bring stuff home or make
stuff at home that he could enjoy and not feel deprived,
but that wouldn't cause him to do this up and down thing.
So I was just starting to experiment at home just for me personally.
And about the same time,
um,
my publisher chronicle called me and said,
okay,
we're interested in doing a third book with you.
And I was like,
great.
Meyerson Chang.
And they said,
no,
we actually think that's a low sugar book.
Would be something that people would be really interested in.
I thought,
okay,
I'm doing this at home.
This could be a thing.
I wasn't positive.
And then literally,
probably about a week later,
um,
Oprah magazine emailed instead,
we want you to write an article about five desserts with no sugar.
Can you do it?
And I just thought this,
this is just meant to be,
it's a sign.
I don't know.
I,
so I did these five desserts for the magazine.
Um,
and I sent them to chronicle books and I said,
what do you think?
And they said,
this is your next book.
So I spent about a year testing recipes.
Um,
and this was really challenging for me because the first two books are all
recipes that currently exist there.
There are things that we serve every day at the bakery that I have recipes for
that we make a huge batch sizes.
So with the first and second book,
uh,
I just had to reduce the batch size,
but for this third book I had to make up recipes for pretty much every single
recipe.
Just start from scratch.
Yeah,
that was really interesting to read in your introduction,
some of the stuff about and throughout the book,
how you were able to test recipes and the ones that you thought might not work.
Like the monkey bread recipe that you said actually did work and I haven't had a
chance to make it,
but it looks really good.
I'm really,
I'm actually curious if there were any recipes that you thought would work or
that you tried really hard to make work that you just couldn't get with low
sugar.
Yeah,
there was,
there's one recipe that still in my head because I still want to try to figure
it out.
Um,
so there's lemon pudding cake.
Have you ever had lemon pudding cake?
It's a,
it's a really easy cake batter that you,
you make this cake batter,
you put it in a pan,
you bake it,
and naturally the cake part floats to the top.
And then at the bottom is a layer of pudding.
Um,
it's a really simple,
wonderful dessert.
And I thought I would love to do a low sugar,
no sugar version,
but with maple syrup.
And I thought maybe I can make a maple putting cake.
And I imagined like this top layer of cake floating to the top,
that was kind of like a pancake and then maybe like a creamy maple leaf sauce at
the bottom.
Does that sound good?
Like it's exactly like I had the,
the vision of what it was going to taste like head.
Um,
I must've made maple putting cake like every week,
probably for the whole year.
I feel like it was about the whole year of writing the book and it just kept
being that,
that recipe that I was like,
I'm gonna try it again next week.
I'm going to try it again next week.
I never got it.
I never got to get that.
Uh,
I think what happens is you have to,
you have to do something with the eggs that involves sugar,
that doesn't work with maple in order to get the putting to sink in the cake to
rise.
So well that,
that brings me to an interesting question too,
is the science behind sugar.
And there were things like moraines that you said you knew you couldn't really,
um,
even bother doing.
Could you tell us a little bit about what low sugar means in this cookbook and
uh,
and maybe also a little bit about the science,
sugar and what makes certain,
what,
how it helps make certain things work the way they do in baking?
I thought so I thought that the biggest challenge in writing this book was going
to be figuring out how to replicate the sweetness in desserts because you're
eliminating sugar.
Um,
because that's what we think of is sugar,
right?
It's sweet.
So if you have something that has less sugar,
it's going to be less sweet.
So how do I trick the pallet into thinking that it's still tastes sweet,
but that ended up being the easiest part of the book in part because we are very
adaptable and it works with salt and it works with sugar.
If you go without salt or if you go without sugar,
um,
I don't know the exact time it takes,
but after awhile your palate just starts to naturally prefer the less salt or
the less sugar.
And it's the same with more salt and more sugar.
The more you eat of sugar and the more you eat of salt,
the more your palate adjust to that and then you things you want things that are
more sugary or more salty.
Um,
so that part was easy in that once I started testing these recipes with less
sugar for me,
I recognize that things that were less sweet tasted just as good,
if not better,
but the challenging part was the chemistry of sugar because sugar does so many
other things than just Sweden.
Uh,
the main,
well there's a bunch of main things,
but one of the big things that sugar does is it's hygroscopic,
which means that it,
it attracts moisture in the air and so it attracts water.
And so in any baked good that has sugar in it,
it sits there on the counter.
And as it's sitting there,
it's attracting water model molecules from the air,
which,
and bringing it to itself.
And that's what makes the pastry stay moist for a couple of days.
So you can make a cake today and still serve it tomorrow or the next day.
And it'll still be great if it has the regular amount of sugar.
As you start to reduce sugar,
it'll taste great when it's fresh out of the oven.
And then maybe by tonight or maybe by tomorrow it's dry because it doesn't have
that,
the sugars to draw in all the moisture.
Um,
another thing that sugar does is that it,
uh,
caramelizes when it's in the oven.
And so when you're making something like a cookie,
the sugar combines with,
uh,
all of the other ingredients in the batter and then it hits that oven heat and
then it starts to caramelize.
And that's what allows the cookie to be kind of crunchy on the outside and then
maybe a little soft on the inside.
So it's really challenging to get texture right when you don't have sugar or if
you have less sugar.
I think that was a really big challenge.
Another thing that sugar does,
which is kind of in line with the characterization,
is that it adds color to baked goods.
And so,
you know,
any picture you,
if you imagine like a beautiful,
uh,
Vanilla cake you just see like golden bright,
every baking instruct,
every recipe says bake till Golden Brown,
but you can't bake things till Golden Brown if there's no sugar because it will
never get that way.
Um,
and that was for me something that took me a while to,
to recognize I was making the carrot cake,
which is actually the cover photo in the book.
And the carrot cake doesn't have any sugar in it,
but it has apple juice.
It has reduced to apple juice.
And I kept baiting,
you know,
making this batter and testing it and tasting it and saying,
okay,
it tastes sweet enough,
putting it into the oven.
And then I do everything by,
I don't do it by time because ovens are different and everything's always
different.
So at this point I just look at things and I touched them and the first couple
of rounds of this cake,
I would keep it in there until it got brown,
which it turns out it was pretty much burnt because it doesn't Brown without the
sugar.
And so when you pull it out of the oven,
it looks really Pale.
It looks at the same color as it did when it,
when it goes in,
it's just a little bit more solid.
So you have to get used to that when you're not baking with as much sugar.
I really liked the way you have the chapters organized.
Um,
it starts with the lower sugar recipes and then goes into just chocolate,
um,
honey maple and then fruit.
Uh,
why did you decide,
what was your reasoning behind organizing it in that way?
While we wanted,
I wanted to ease people into the idea.
So the first chapter is,
it's probably about 10 or 12 recipes of things that we all eat every day,
um,
that have less sugar.
So not no sugar.
So the,
the Fudgy Moscow brownies that I've been in,
the banana bread,
yellow birthday cake,
a coconut Chiffon cake,
all of those have white sugar in them,
but at least half the amount or even less than your standard recipe.
So I wanted to just kind of introduce the,
the baker or the reader to the idea that you can reduce sugar and still have
something that tastes great.
Um,
and in fact we have samples of the oatmeal raisin walnut cookie that is made
with a third of the amount of sugar as the standard recipe.
So that was the first chapter.
And then I wanted to,
and then in terms of grouping at according to flavors,
um,
a big reason you asked earlier why did I want to write the book and I gave you a
couple of reasons.
Another reason is that sugar itself doesn't actually taste like anything.
It's just sweet.
Whereas sweeteners like maple and honey and fruit,
they actually have flavor and they add a whole nother dimension of flavor to
whatever it is that you're making.
And a big part of writing this book was recognizing that if you don't use sugar
as your sweetener,
but instead turn to a natural sweetener like a honey or maple or molasses,
you're adding that flavor to your baked good,
which is in my world,
a really great thing.
It's like you have something that tastes good and you add more flavor to it,
that's even better.
So I wanted to group it accordingly so that if you,
if you're somebody who really likes honey and if you like that flavor of honey,
here's a whole bunch of recipes that allow you to use that rather than white
sugar in making your baked goods.
Yeah.
And I told you I made the lemon recut the cupcakes,
which are just sweetened with honey and it was great and you would never have
known that the frosting even didn't have any sugar in it.
That's great.
Um,
so I did notice that the only cheesecake recipe in here is a cheesecake
maple bars,
something like that.
The pumpkin.
Yeah.
Come get in.
That's what it was.
Um,
was there any reason that you didn't?
I happen to love cheesecakes,
so of course I'm asking about.
She's good.
It was there any reason you didn't do,
uh,
just a regular straight up cheesecake or just as it happened was no reason
is that we were,
um,
I wanted to do something with Pumpkin.
Um,
and we've often,
we've often talked about introducing a Pumpkin cheesecake during the
Thanksgiving period,
um,
at the bakery.
And so I was thinking that we could do something,
I mean pumpkin goes well with maple,
but we already have in the book,
um,
uh,
maple pumpkin pie.
Um,
so then I,
I got really interested and excited about baking with dates and so this recipe
has dates in the base and then the actual cheesecake is sweetened with unreduced
apple juice,
which is one of the,
the go tos in the fruit chapter.
So I was just,
again,
you bring in so many more flavors when you are working with fruits versus just
with sugar.
And I wanted to try out mixing apple and Pumpkin and it all worked out great.
That's awesome.
So,
uh,
again we were talking about this before.
I had thought about going to culinary school for Pastry Arts at one point,
almost dropped out of Grad school to do it and decided instead,
not to in part because I was worried that if I did something that I loved doing
at home and on my own time all the time for work,
I wouldn't enjoy it as much anymore.
So do you still like baking?
So love baking?
I don't bake as much as I used to for sure.
Uh,
you know,
the first six years of the bakery I was baking every day.
Um,
and then when we opened the second location,
I,
my role shifted so that I was no longer in the kitchen every single day.
Um,
but I was still in the kitchen probably about half the time.
And then when we opened Cambridge,
the third location,
then it shifted entirely out of the kitchen.
Um,
so I bake now when I'm testing recipes for a book,
um,
and I'll bake,
you know,
at home just for special occasions.
But,
uh,
it's still something that I enjoy.
But as a,
as somebody who,
if you enjoy baking and you want to do it professionally,
I mean not that I think you guys are looking for career changes,
but if you were,
um,
it is just,
it is very,
very different to do it professionally.
It's a job.
It's still work.
You know,
I think we get a lot of people who,
a lot of career changers who come to us and say,
I bake a lot at home and I really love it and I want to come,
you know,
learn how to make cookies at flower.
And everybody loves it for about two weeks,
sometimes three weeks.
And then the reality hits it and it's like everyday you're going to come in and
you're going to crack,
you know,
20 flats of eggs and then you're going to do this and you're,
and nothing changes.
Like there's,
there's just a lot of detail and work and it's hard and it's sweaty and you
know,
it's still work.
So when you're baking at home,
you obviously have freedom to do whatever you want and you get to eat it
whenever you want.
And if it doesn't work out,
no big deal,
you just make something else.
It doesn't really work like that at work.
So I always try to make understand that it's,
it's still really fun to make it work,
but it's just a different type of fun.
Sure.
Uh,
so my last question before we open it up to the audience is we have backyard
hens and so I often have a refrigerator full of two,
three dozen eggs.
What's your favorite recipe that uses a lot of eggs?
Uh,
let's see.
Recipes that use love eggs.
I mean sweet or savory.
Either way it would be sweet.
The chiffon cake that's in this book actually,
or any angel food cake or Chiffon cake,
um,
is,
is great for using a lot of eggs.
I think the,
the angel food cake in the first book I think uses 12 eggs and we think this
cake might use to eight or,
or 12 eggs.
Any custard basically is going to use a lot of egg yolks.
So in pastry you're always using egg yolks for the most part.
And you're always trying to find something to do with the egg white.
So I feel like ice creams use a lot of egg,
egg yolks and then Marangu since Chiffon cakes and angel food cakes use a lot of
egg whites you can make to an angel food cake in a giant customer.
Exactly.
So if there are questions in the audience,
there are microphones set up in the isles a piece.
When you experiment with cooking,
do you remember like any really big surprises where you didn't think two things,
we're going to compliment each other or go together and they ended up being
great.
Uh,
and Cook and baking you mean?
I mean I do mostly mostly dabbling around in baking.
Um,
let's see.
Two things that we combined that came out great.
Well,
I mean I was surprised at this Pumpkin,
Pumpkin and apple even though pumpkin pie and apple pie sound good.
I've never had pumpkin apple pie.
So when we were trying,
when I was doing the cheesecake,
I was trying to figure out if,
I mean it's a double edge sword,
you're adding the flavor of apple to anything that you sweetened with apple
juice,
which is great unless it doesn't go well with apple.
So that actually ended up being really great because Pumpkin is really rich and
earthy and apple is kind of acidic.
And so I often feel like when I'm eating Pumpkin I want something a little bit
brighter anyway.
And so by sweetening the Pumpkin with a little bit of apple,
it actually,
for me it's much more rounded,
balanced dessert.
So that was something that I wasn't expecting.
You were talking about having to experiment about the
topic and I was just curious,
did you play it all with temperature for things like baking cakes or or whatnot?
Um,
at the end.
So you could try and trap the,
uh,
the water at the,
at the tail end of the cooking process or,
okay.
Well we did experiment with a temperature just because there are things that
will,
that you still need them to bake,
but they don't.
Brown.
And so you're kind of like adjusting and anything with honey or maple,
you want to bake it a little bit less lower temperature anyway,
but the hygroscopic is for when af when it's done and then it's sitting on the
counter or an on the shelf or whatever.
That's when that element comes into play more than in the baking,
like in the,
in the oven.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
Like it's just throwing it in the freezer at the end wouldn't necessarily help
it help capture the water inside of the,
uh,
the cake.
No,
it would if you had a cake and if he wanted just to delay that,
that evaporation or the drying,
you could definitely slow it down by putting it in the freezer.
Okay.
For sure.
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you so much for coming.
And my question's not about less sugar,
but one of my favorite treats at flower.
Are They Vegan?
My friend.
Do you have like a Vegan Vanilla Barry and yeah.
Again,
banana,
chocolate chip and then any time I eat a vegan treat anywhere else,
it's like really dry and gross.
So,
I don't know if it's a thicker pair of say that and I don't know if it's a
secret,
but I've always wondered like what you do with your Vegan treats to make them
taste just as good as some of the other ones.
Well,
thank you.
Um,
the Vegan muffin recipe is in the second book flower too.
and what we do is,
you know,
I don't know what other people are doing,
but we just substitute the things that,
I mean,
if you're Vegan then you already know,
like instead of milk we use soy milk or coconut milk.
Instead of butter,
we use oil.
Uh,
we didn't do anything for the game instead of eggs.
I think we just kind of fiddled around and with the oil and the milk to make it
still liquid enough.
Um,
but I don't know that we did anything.
You know,
that magic,
there's no magic to it.
I mean,
it's,
it's in,
it's in the book.
I think we just,
I mean,
we spend a lot of time when we do come up with a new recipe,
we spend a lot of time experimenting.
Um,
everything is weighed at the bakery,
everything is weighed to the gram and we will literally change things by one to
2% iteration after iteration to get to where we want it to be.
In fact,
there's an email thread going on right now about something that they're like,
should we up at 5%?
And I was like,
nope,
let's start with 3%.
Let's try it first,
just 3% and then we'll see what happens.
Um,
so there's a lot of testing.
So the recipe for the Vegan muffin that you're talking about,
um,
went through many rounds of,
maybe it started out dry at one point.
Let me just add it more and more stuff.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Hi Joanne.
Thanks so much for coming today.
I'm curious if you could talk a little bit about your process for testing
recipes for a cookbook and how many,
if there's like an average number of times you test a few,
throw it to other people to test to make sure it's accessible for the novice
speaker.
Sure.
So if it's a recipe that we already have,
like the Vegan muffin recipe,
which exists at the bakery,
um,
basically what happens is,
so everything's in metric and I just reduce it to what seems like a normal home,
size them out,
and then I'll test it myself.
Um,
and I'll go through it once,
but just because I can do it,
I know that that doesn't mean that it's ready for the book because I know what
I'm thinking.
So I need to give it to somebody else.
So then a baker,
we'll test it within the bakery just to make sure that it's kind of the right
thing.
But even that doesn't really work for,
from a testing perspective because all the baker's know me and they know what I
mean when I say do this,
do that.
So then we send it out and we have a Cambridge culinary,
they will test recipes for us for class credit.
And so there's a whole,
um,
depending on,
you know,
whenever semester I'll reach out to the director and she'll put me in touch with
that class and they are on my email list and I say,
here's a bunch of recipes I need tested.
Um,
and then I have a couple of testers who are just people that I've worked closely
with who just test for me.
So it will take,
I mean if it's something that already existed,
the bakery,
it doesn't take that many iterations because we already do it.
It's just a matter of figuring out like sometimes as you reduce,
reduce,
it reduces to a weird number.
It reduces to like one cup plus two tablespoons and one teaspoon,
you know,
and that's not really that usable.
So I'll have to change things around and change the proportions around just to
make sure that somebody at home can,
can actually do it.
Um,
but that doesn't usually take,
usually takes like one,
one try,
maybe two tries.
But if it's a brand new recipe,
like with the low sugar book,
that would,
I feel like those recipes,
a good recipe would take four iterations by me.
So that's me trying it out and then adjusting,
adjusting,
and then by the fourth time being like,
okay,
I think this works.
Then I would give it to a baker and then they would do it and usually again,
it was almost the same thing as my doing it.
They know me well enough that they would just make it so that's like a fifth
test and then we would send it out to the testers and usually from there I would
say about 80% of the time it worked in 20% of the time I'd get feedback like
this isn't really working.
So then we adjust it.
But by that it was usually just one iteration because I would get specific
feedback.
I would say,
ah,
I knew that that was going to happen.
Let me adjust this.
So that's a good recipe.
A bad recipe or not a bad recipe.
No bad recipes.
More challenging recipe.
Probably more like eight or nine times.
I mean,
it's just like there's,
again,
because we're doing things in such small,
in pastry,
there's so many things that you can vary,
right?
If you have 10 ingredients in your thing,
in your recipe and you're trying to make it more moist or less sweet or
whatever,
if you just adjust one thing,
it's going to affect everything else.
So what you want to do is adjust everything,
but then you don't know which one of those adjustments worked in which one
doesn't.
So you have to kind of go slowly and say,
well,
I'm just going to reduce the eggs from four eggs to three eggs and see what
happens.
Then you have to wait until it bakes,
wait until it cools,
try it and then do it again.
So it takes a lot of patients,
but,
but it's a lot of fun and there's a lot of mistakes along the way that most
people don't use mistakes.
So people like to eat the mistakes.
If you need a test us for your next book,
um,
I'd be happy to send recipes out to the office.
Our office is very good.
One,
a test recipes.
Sure.
Hi.
Um,
I wondered about a convection oven versus conventional in which is your goto and
in what cases will you opt for the other choice and why?
We use mostly convection at this point.
Um,
but it's for,
but it's for a specific pastries.
So for cookies,
Brioche Muffins,
um,
and tarts,
tart shells,
we'll use convection and we'll use deck ovens or the still ovens for things like
bread and cakes.
And the difference with the convection,
you know,
you've got the fan warring around which is making the temperature more
consistent,
but it is introducing the element of movement and air.
And so for a cookie or a brioche or something that it's relatively stable,
I don't mind that there's air blowing around because I just want it to bake and
I want it to bake relatively evenly.
I don't want half of the Brioche to be under and a half to be over.
Um,
but a cake,
if you put a cake in a convection oven,
what tends to happen is that the cake starts to cook on the outside because
you've got the scoring fan and then the inside is still needing time to cook.
And so the cake will sometimes come out like crispier on the outside.
Like it'll,
it'll finish baking on the outside first.
And by the time the inside is baked,
it'll be over baked on the outside.
So we have found that these still ovens are better for baking cakes because it's
slow,
steady heat.
There's no air that's trying to like basically form across.
And that's the same with bread.
If you put bread in the convection oven,
the air will cause the,
the skin of the bread to crust,
which means that as the yeast is trying to expand and as the brand's trying to
get big and airy,
it can't because it's been crusted over.
So we prefer doing that and it's still oven.
And an even better is if you can inject some steam in it,
take a little water bottle and put some scene.
It creates a really humid environment for the bread.
So then the bread dose stays supple as the East is growing and then it doesn't
crust over until the Easter all dead.
And then it's,
and then you get the crust that's characteristic of really good bread.
So that's how we differentiate.
Great.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I,
so I had a question about how do you decide which recipes to share?
I mean,
are there,
do you have a collection of recipes that you're never going to share that or
like the secret ones or,
okay.
Uh,
the first book was all the recipes that we had at the time and then since then
we've done new things and people will say,
how come you didn't share this recipe?
And I'll say,
cause we hadn't made it at that point.
Um,
and the same with the second book,
you know,
we,
I put a bunch of Salads and the second book and then we came up with a new salad
menu at the bakery and everyone's like,
where's the green goddess dressing?
And I said,
all,
we hadn't made it by then.
So the issue for us now as if somebody wants a recipe that hasn't been tested,
I can give you the recipe to make like 10 gallons of green goddess.
And if you want to do the math or I can do the math as well and just give it to
you in grams.
But I don't have,
I don't have home friendly recipes for everything.
So that's usually the limiting factor.
And I'll,
if somebody says,
I love this recipe,
I'll just say to them,
I can give it to you in the big batch and I can do the math,
you know,
just divide it by,
50 or whatever.
But depending on your,
your comfort level,
you can either use it or it won't really help.
So I don't really feel like recipes are meant to be.
Um,
I feel like recipes are meant to be shared.
a lot of that comes from the fact that we obviously use the same recipe at the
bakery for all of our items.
Every Baker has,
you know,
access to the big recipe book.
And it's crazy the variation that comes,
even though everything is weighed,
you know,
to the gram and everything is timed,
to the,
almost to the second.
And yet we will still have huge variations because to me baking isn't just
about,
I mean everyone talks about how baking is chemistry and it's so precise and it
is,
but it's also so much about who you are and what you put into it and how you're
feeling that day.
And I know that sounds very like touchy feely,
but I really feel like pastry is something that you can tell if somebody's doing
it right and doing it well.
And so giving somebody the recipe,
isn't it the secret?
It's,
it's just,
it's all the thought and the care and the attention that goes into making it.
That's the secret.
So I'm happy to share all the recipes and hope that everybody has that same
thought and care.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I think we're out of audience questions.
I love that last thing that you said because I've always said that,
um,
my art is speaking and that I put love into everything that I make.
And so I do that for gifts for people,
for holidays and everything.
So it was awesome that you said that.
Thank you so much for coming.
Yeah.